mais bonsoir bienvenue pour ce diagonale
spécial olympiades bonsoir et loire
bonsoir stéphane bonsoir à tous
olympiades résultats de la france pas
mal puisqu'il termine 16e c'est la
russie qui l'emportent
alors 52 minutes c'est qu'on ait mis
deux folies comme tu disais tout à
l'heure et loi puisque aujourd'hui on
reçoit pour commenter ces olympiades qui
sont vraiment un événement phare du jeu
d'échecs entre les nations et chicken on
reçoit un membre de l'équipe de france
raymond de l'équipe de france et non pas
et pas le moindre puisqu'il s'agit de
notre star à diagonale celui qu'on aime
bien le petit laurent frayssinet bosseur
de ronsard stéphane alors eloi pardon
laurent tu ne reviens directement donc
d'istanbul où donc tu as tu as joué
c'est au lecteur comment ça s'est passé
l'équipe de france fait un très bon
résultat 16e c'est un des meilleurs
résultats je crois dans l'histoire de
l'équipe de france comme ça c'est passé
qu'elle était l'équipe l'ambiance les
russes ont utilisé était difficile à
battre et c'est un message les russes
ont été difficiles à battre
en plus on a fait le contraire on a
perdu 3 1 donc on peut on peut confirmer
et disant que les russes en ont très
bien joué de bout en bout et ont été
boostées dix ans par des bons résultats
sur la fin ils ont gagné 1 4 0 parce
qu'ils font appeler c'est un classement
par points non pas par match gagné
c'est ce qui m'a le plus haut point qui
gagne il ya quatre joueurs d'une équipe
qui rencontrait quatre joueurs de
l'autre voilà un quatre parties donc
voila et peu importe le résultat final
du match
c'est pas comme au football où on compte
le nombre de points quand on gagne un
match il faut marquer le plus de points
deux parties en fait pour simplifier
si on gagne un match 4 0 c'est beaucoup
beaucoup mieux que le gagner 2
mais voilà ça fait un point et demi
supplémentaires alors que m'enfin bref
en gros c'est les points deux partis qui
comptent et ça c'est ça change tout
voilà tout à fait et donc pour l'équipe
de france ça s'est bien passé de bout en
bout on a joué des très bonnes équipes
comme la russie la hongrie
l'angleterre qui étaient les trois
meilleures nations ou des au début du
tournoi avec des trois meilleures
moyennes et l'eau et donc c'est vrai
qu'on a eu des hauts et des bas c'est
vrai qu'entre les formations on a eu
beaucoup de mal à jouer à gagner les
matches on les a pratiquement tous
perdus on est battu la suisse qui a une
assez bonne nation
mais c'est vrai qu'on est bien revenu
sur la fin et malgré un appariement
assez défavorable aux à l'avant dernière
ronde où on a joué l'espagne qui avait
une demi point de plus que nous il faut
savoir que les deux derniers rentrent
sont très importantes forcément vu que
c'est une chaussure 4 0 2 x 4 0 est
remontée d'un dernier cinq premiers donc
on a joué l'espagne qui était avec
sheikh en fait aux premiers échiquiers
donc déjà shirov quand on joue contre
chir en fac baignoire on porte pas
forcément favoris reconnaît en plus
voyez japonais j'échoue contenu donc je
peux je peux confirmer aussi et donc
c'est vrai qu'on appelle un appariement
et à la dernière ronde dangereux quand
le kirghizstan qui est une nation un peu
moins forte que nous et on a eu ce coup
de booster 3/2 0 et demi on a fait un
match énorme on peut même en poney 1 on
peut dire ça et on sait tous on sait
tous surpassés et est donc finalement on
arrive à cette très belle 16e place
alors très belle et un petit peu
étonnante on va dire parce que c'est pas
a priori l'équipe de france la plus
forte qui étaient là bas
pardon mais ça pour ça d'ailleurs je me
rappelle je me rappelle tant
l'expression des équipes light
oui voilà carlotti et macro et mais il
faut dire que le team macro il ya deux
ans et cette équipe de france avait
terminé 32e
donc je sais pas si
et il n'y avait pas eu de bonnes
relations entre les joueurs et pour les
20 ans à venir que la symbiose dans une
équipe ça joue mal aux échecs je pense
que ces essais c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
est très agréable de jouer moi j'adore
jouer en équipe
parce que dans un sport aussi
individuelles que les échecs je crois
que c'est
c'est bien d'avoir justement de
retrouver cet esprit d'équipé d'être
donc ça ressemble un peu la coupe davis
mais on peut dire ça voilà ça ne peut
comparer à ça et est donc cesser c'était
vraiment c'est j'aime beaucoup ce jeu
j'aime beaucoup jouer à l'équipe de
france parce que justement on retrouve
on retrouve cet esprit et cet esprit
équipe quand qu'on ne voit jamais dans
les tours à comment on fait
individuellement on va revenir sur ce
parcours très bon de l'équipe de france
et on a pu noter que les résultats
finaux de ce bunker je pensais d'abord
commencé par présenter les résultats
individuels de l'équipe de france oui
c'est à dire communiqué christian bauer
oui ils sont beaux à voir ça paraît
naturel en l'absence de lautier bacrot
et éventuellement you steve dark bane de
le mettre au premier agiter ses
résultats étant évidemment dernièrement
très bon il a fait une bonne performance
puisqu'il fait six points sur 11 c'est
pas mal avec notamment une nulle contre
qualif même
à noter qu'au premier league et si le
plus dur puisque en mangeant ils sont
les premiers échiquiers des autres
nations ont donc a priori le meilleur
joueur quoi oui effectivement et à la
fin donc question aurait calmé jo il a
un peu levé le pied ou peut-être que
l'on va pouvoir nous confirmer ça il a
au début il est parti assez fort en
gagnant trois parties et après beaucoup
de nuls suivi d'une perte contre
l'espagne contre chir venouil donc la
veille de cette partie quand tu en fis a
joué contre adams avec les blancs et en
fait nous notre notre plan c'était de le
faire jouer des deux dernières rondes
absolument et il se trouvait que s'ils
sortaient contre l'angleterre on voulait
faire sortir dix ans anthouard en avant
l' affaire c'était un orateur qui
rentrait et
et donc ils grand batave qui avait des
résultats assez assez calamiteuse donc
on va y arriver et donc avec les blancs
contre adam sont là juste dit de faire
nul en dix coups pour assurer au moins
un demi point à l'équipe et c'est ce qui
s'est passé au cg remarque de grève qui
était très en forme et on lui a dit de
faire nul compte dans ce match on a nos
terres nous on a un peu sacrifié le
match contre l'angleterre en faisant
souffrir les deux grilles noires n'ayant
ni igor igor nataf et moi on a perdu
donc la peur du match 3 1 mais bon on
garder nos deux joueurs très en forme
pour les deux dernières rondes et
c'était vraiment capital d'accor ça vous
allez jouer
vous les avez fait jouer avec les blancs
ils ont fait des nuls assez rapide
facile et ensuite ils sont enfants pour
les deux d'un appartement elle sera
jouée micoud donc c'est comme s'il y
avait une journée pour enfin à noter
quand même que faire mieux contre adams
même avec les blancs ou 8 pouces et
c'est comme une marque de respect de la
dame dont christian bauer toujours en
forme qui terminent donc à +16 points
sur 11 c'est pas mal igor nataf deuxième
échiquier alors déjà pourquoi your
deuxième échiquier l'on ignore de
l'échiquier parce que il a dit qu'il
avait une invitation au cap d'agde n'est
donc que lui voulait jouer aux
olympiades pour jouer contre d'efforts
je leur ai donc il a déclaré devant les
olympiades que s'il ne jouait pas au
premier ou au second c'est l'intéressé
pas il préférait un léger au cap d'agde
il voulait rentrer absolument des bons
joueurs et donc c'est pour ça qu'il a
donc igor qui a fait tout un joueur sans
compromis qui est là pour jouer des
joueurs forts
donc à demander cette deuxième place
c'est effectivement malheureusement ça
s'est pas bien passé il aurait très fort
c'est que mes remarques à ce que j'ai
noté c'est qu'il en a fait l'un des
rares français est qualifié shop la nuit
en enfer rare non quand même pas bauer
aussi car de trop une antenne macro je
vais lautier chef collection contient
prix français encore d'un gain et boris
spassky lyon nombreux espaces libres et
donc
tous ces joueurs là ne jouez pas les
mêmes cadres parce qu'il se préparait
pour championnat du monde notamment
lautier aussi se préparer avec rami que
c'est le seul patron qui se prépare une
dizaine d'années qui se préparait pour
les lots chapelle demande de dorfman
aussi peut-être pas dans une hormone
ibad hoffman a des problèmes
d'équipement lien mais le capitaine oui
donc il voulait pas jouer et donc après
les autres quel chef il est pas français
parce que dans la taf aurait pas dû se
préparer plus tôt pour ce championnat du
monde que jouer les américano si bon
chemin bref bon c'est un choix qu'il a
fait donc igor nataf bref c'est la
catastrophe de l'équipe puisqu'il fait
deux ans et demi sur vite c'est
clairement le plus mauvais score et
gagne ses deux premières parties contre
l'irlande et la belgique
et ensuite il enchaîne avec quatre
défaites consécutives c'est délirant et
en lire en veillant à la belgique
autant pour moi et en plus faut signaler
que ces deux partis qui a gagné c'était
un et final et comme sur de plus
complètement nu l'île des conquérants
c'était cavaliers pyongyang et maliens
et l'autre a choisi un mauvais chemin
pour cent cavaliers à paris c'est raté
pions pour adapter en terrasse est donc
enfin donc un igor nataf en très petite
forme
espérons que ce n'est pas de mauvaise
augure pour lancer une crypte an
prochain on verra bien troisième
échiquier jean-marc degraeve donc
jean-marc on le connaît il est devenu à
diagonale faut évidemment le revoir dans
les archives
c'est lui qui fait le meilleur score
qu'il fait un très bon score 7 sur 10
aucune défaite
hawking défaite très solide perf à 2650
points elo très bien joué de la part de
jean marc leroux il était en forme et
s'il faut en activité un vraiment super
forme et comme on a vu quand il est
quand il commence bien il n'a pas très
bien commencé mais après il est revenu
très vite les deux premiers on n'y a pas
très bien joué il a fait mieux avec des
2350 vers prix est revenu et comment la
vue aux championnes de france quand il
est en confiance il avait je me rappelle
aux championnats de france il avait
battu bacrot bauer et mois d'affilée il
avait même refusé à la normale avant de
perdre sur une grosse erreur
donc quand il commence à être en
confiance comme ça je crois que rien ne
peut l'arrêter il a battu al majid
et qu'il est blanc et noir ils cherchent
à fond c'est jean-marie très bon joueur
je ne pas pas également que le signal
est donc bonne bonne vie de famille
c'est pour ça qu'il était un peu fatigué
peut-être pour ça qu'il est très motivé
et un peu fatigué au début 4e échiquier
quelqu'un qu'on aime bien diagonale
aussi arnaud charrin hochart nos chars
qui a un qui a pas mal joué six points
sur neuf
qu'advient il des fêtes une défaite
contre un joueur russe les visiteurs
pourront spidla effectivement c'est pas
facile on connaissait leur île et dans
les dix meilleurs joueurs mondiaux et
quelqu'un c'est bien donc bonne
performance d'arnaud charles iv l
échiquier sonné le 101 sont des loups
oui par france a sondé les performances
à ceux des ministres de mai à trois
points à 3 points de très solides comme
des minutes d'antenne non non c'est
toujours agréable d'avoir un acquis
parce qu'on sait que on sait que la
valeur sûre c'est la valeur sûre mais on
sait que bon il ya peut-être pas gagner
tous les partis mais disons qu'il ya
perdra pas beaucoup
et en plus il est sympa donc là ces
biens soient calmes échiquier laurent
frayssinet donc long qui nous a déjà
détaillé un peu sommes pas en bon
parcours au sein de grands moyens très
moyen les objets sûr j'ai été j'ai été
très mauvais et baignoire pour le faux
liens j'ai perdu 2 h dorff terrible j'ai
vraiment chez vraiment très mal joué a
eu les blancs j'ai plutôt bien joué mais
bon c'est juste pour attraper mais les
erreurs et les noirs et donc j'ai fait
une perf à peu près à mon lots et
utilisez donc avec ses blanc tu fais une
performance à 2700 est arrivé noir à
2306 voilà c'est ça donc un gros écart
j'ai très bien joué
c'est comme cette année j'ai beaucoup de
problèmes c'est un j'ai commencé à jouer
une ouverture très tendu qui est la
défense des doors et donc
l'apprentissage
et douloureux est tombé d'accord
sixième à chiquer emmanuel api c'est là
donc ça c'était le seul joueur litigieux
dans cette équipe
enfin notez qu'à six joueurs évidemment
il ya des remplaçants c'est un peu comme
davis aussi on parle de coupe davis
c'est pas forcément les mêmes joueurs
qui font tous les matchs voilà et donc y
avait donc deux joueurs d'ailleurs les
le nombre de partis on peut voir a été
assez bien réparé oui tout à fait les
deux joueurs très enfants qui ont joué
plus de partis et les quatre joueurs qui
étaient en fin mai migrants la taf qui
était moins en forme qui a joué moi on
l'a pas fait jouer sur la fin et les
trois autres ont été dans leur forme et
aux normales on peut détailler 13
parties en tous genres moteur d'autres
14 jean marc et et christian bauer on a
joué 11 et 10 10 et 11 vous 3 c'est à
dire arnaud hauchard laurent frayssinet
emmanuel avis et leurs jouets neufs et
grenat tard seulement 8
effectivement il fallait arrêter les
frais sur la fin donc manuela peas et là
c'est le joueur qui était un peu
discutable dans cette équipe dans la
mesure où il n'était pas sûr d'être
qualifié c'est lui qui avait fait la
moins bonne performance aux championnats
de france rappelle que cet été andré
qualificatif mais il fume beaucoup mais
finalement dont il fait un score plus 2
c'est-à-dire de gains enfin l'équivalent
de guerre et que des nuls donc cinq et
demi sur neuf avec donc deux défaites
quatre gains et notamment évidemment le
gain la dernière partie qui vaut très
cher puisque ça fait une grosse
différence si on perd cette dernière
ombre évidemment secret si on s'y perd
des six opérations mais les deux ennemis
réunis en finisse et 25e donc c'est
clair que c'était très important il a
été et est bien motivé en plus jouer le
matin pour lui ça lui quand on est
peut-être plus qu'à d'autres d'un qu'il
a été il était plutôt il a toujours une
et les qualités qu'on lui connaît c'est
à dire
combatif et tout est peut-être contre
les très fort joueur il n'arrive pas à
cause son répertoire d'ouvertures ans il
est un peu limité et il a souvent du mal
à avoir des bonnes positions et donc
souvent ça c'est pas terrible donc voilà
pour cette équipe de france
pas mal homogène solide esprit d'équipé
sympathie et je crois que l'organisation
était très bonne
d'après les échos qu'on a vu sur
internet c'était pas mal où il me sens
plus à la banque s'était s'était pas
extra c'était le site et pas mal
l'autorité correct le la salle était
bien oui c'était d'être comparé à
d'autres domaines on s'est passé mais je
sais pas j'ai pas fait les olympiens
voilà c'est pour ça qu'on a pas de point
de comparaison
voilà alors pour finir on va donner plus
au final au dossier de la fascine c'est
une idée on va terminer par phare de
faire ce placement oui c'est quand même
pas facile à organiser ce type de
manifestation parce qu'il ya comme une
pays 130 130 130 pays et un peuple
c'est l'une des plus grosses
manifestations même mondial tous sports
confondus mais sachant que chaque pays à
mennecy joueurs pour l'équipe masculine
et 4 pour l'été venu le singel quelle
vitesse ça fait dix mille trois cents
personnes puissent le capitaine
éventuellement d'autres ça commence à
faire beaucoup mieux beaucoup
nationalité et ça dure trop longtemps
stéphane c'est à dire quinze jours comme
dans une grande salle
donc c'est ainsi effectivement un
événement des gens mal en point ces
événements ouais c'est un événement
assez loin donc classement final
finalement les premiers donc donc les
ruses l'art les rues série sans vraiment
de surprise à noter qu'ils ont quand
même été très très paniqué au début
puisque les allemands ont été en tête
pendant très longtemps
alors laurent une explication sur sa
l'équipe d'allemagne qu'est ce qu'elle
est particulier puisque c'est pas une
équipe habituée aux premières places
mais disons que c'est du solide des
amériques
faut dire ce qu'il perd très peu de
parties et puis quand dix ans leur
disons qu'ils jouent très solide et
quand l'enjeu solides marchés qu'ils
arrivent à marquer des points
forcément ça leur fait il ya une
pratiquement tous les matches et ça leur
fait beaucoup de points est arrivé donc
c'est pas toi on est en trouver un donc
russie allemagne trois oppositions
ukraine dans lequel saignant c'est le
meilleur résultat en allemagne de toute
son histoire un olympia des pourris ce
qu'il dit j'ai vu sur les sites
allemands c'est clair l'ukraine alors
j'ai vu une belle équipe y avait autre
chose ponomariov est au-dessus craignant
a été battu oui mais pas avant avant
donc voici 10 bonnes choses très fort
peut dire alors moi je crois que pour
nous mais rajoutent à beaucoup
impressionné ah oui évidemment mais moi
je trouve que pour le mariage ou de
mieux en mieux et bientôt à mon avis
avoir 2700 je sais pas s'il les a déjà
vus que j'ai à chaque tournoi où je les
ai vus il a gagné des points ont donc
moi je suis assez impressionné par
premier mariage maintenant il est encore
plus sûr de lui parce qu'avant et s'il
veut vraiment pas de satam j'ai remarqué
j'allais jouer deux fois conduit seul
oeuvrant pas et là c'est vrai je le
voyais assez souvent debout donc 60 ans
nous concurrencent pas ce que
j'attendais j'ai l'impression qu'ils
font beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
détendue et que ça l'a vraiment c'est
sûr de sa force il sûr de sa force
huit et demi sur 11 ces hausses ne
commet aucune médaille
je sais qu'il a une médaille je sais pas
oui alors le pouls des médailles on les
verra peut-être en fin d'émission
sinoise mutants 5e israël 6e j'ai
parfois le lendemain on a parlé de
languenan landry à égalité l'ukraine en
fait c'est que il le crâne devant au
départage mais ils ont fait le même
nombre de points donc la hongrie
collective de france a rencontré à la mi
temps l'écossé samedi dans l'écho zoltan
almasy ils ont sorti l'artillerie lourde
et provient justice ponia la partie oui
si qui joue dans l'équipe masculine
entre guillemets qu'on y voilà enfin
c'est la meilleure donc c'est la
meilleure donc que la hongrie ensuite
israël géorgie et 7e l'angleterre donc
mauvais résultats la contrepèterie ce
qu'évidemment comme disait laurent les
anglais étaient parmi les trois plus
forts ils terminent que septième alors
qu'ils avaient effectivement le maximum
il y avait michael adams michael short
spillmann il y avait une très belle
équipe d'angleterre
pas mal comme ils ont été handicapés par
miles qui était pas très informé il est
bien un problème de famille il a dû
partir en milieu de tant moi donc
peut-être que ça ça a joué ils ont dû
jouer le plus de parties en pointe de
famille effectivement miles a beaucoup
de problèmes et donc cup comme un petit
coloccini au maximum ce qu'on va faire
partie ou l'inde
neuvième la chine à nos frais valeur des
la chine a noté ça c'est le pays
émergents moi ça c'est pas vraiment une
surprise
à noter que l'inde a joué sans attendre
je prends tarifaire qu'un homme d'état
bastien voilà donc pas de vannes entre
la chine et 10e la suisse c'est la bonne
performance donc voilà pour ce palmarès
la france 16e quand on est battu dans la
suisse voilà la solidarité la tue donc
par la france parce que je crois que
laurent tu as battu et yannick patier
voilà schéma tienne nous y voilà nouveau
curé de nouveaux grands matches de
l'histoire on va quand même oublier
stéphane de préciser quelque chose dans
sa vie la mission le jeune laurent
frayssinet est enfin grand maître oui il
est grand mais se pose donc la copie
depuis ces olympiades officiellement sa
vie mais on savait déjà mais savait déjà
mais là c'était ratifié voila voila tout
à fait alors on va passer à d'autres
parties du jour après sept longues
palabres sur sur ces olympiades avec une
belle très jolie partie on n'a pas
choisi une victoire ne leur impressionné
mais une partie très intéressante
c'était le match contre la hongrie c3m
échiquier c'est ça j'ai joué aux
troisième et chéquiers et tu joues
contre la meilleure joueuse du monde
tu avais
contraire mais non non jamais donc
c'était bien sa part muet c'était sympa
paris - non mais elle était à l'état
c'est sympa payante surtout après la
partie
bref même avant la partie ça allait donc
a fourni quelques commentaires parce que
cinq des partis en elle même et c'est un
débat théorique où j'ai pas été très
rouge et pas été brillants j'étais mieux
préparée qu'elle mais elle a affiché une
heure sur un coût et donc les enfin on
l'espère et si tu te déstabiliser dans
la partie non mais bon la russie car
j'en attends avec les questions de
pervers on va plutôt passer à la télé on
va passer à la technique pure
donc voilà si on peut être l'échiquier
robes en voile a indiqué en plein écran
voilà voilà donc avec cette partie donc
on laurent tu as donc les pièces noires
voilà tout à fait donc le cas classique
elle veut dit ah le mien me jouer comme
avant ça c'était je suis dit oh joue
systématiquement au caire dans la haine
et leur on joue maintenant la cécilienne
sa saison j'ai toujours général justo
longerait sicilienne mais disons que
j'ai joué des d'autres systèmes que le
système ne génère alors avoir ce système
alors qu'amélie f3 en a déjà discuté
normale sur les pièces des six des
quatre actions au centre des prises du
pion cavaliers reprend car il si son
attaque le pion de 4 il faut le protéger
et on se protège en sortant une pièce et
la balle à s'allier première première
premier arrêt à 6 signe la variante donc
l'âge d'or
voilà tout à fait donc cessé d environ
système donc on peut se préparer contre
toi sur ça voilà un exemple vu un usager
en ce moment on peut on peut s'attendre
à ce que je chante le tandem vraiment on
joue pas ça d'habitude
d'accord c'est très difficile alors à 6
effectivement bon ça a été employée par
kasparov par fisher notamment
l'idée de ce coup et la souplesse avant
tout c'est à dire ah si c'est un coup
qu'on a envie de jouer mais ça négligent
effectivement le développement des
pièces puisque ça ne contribue pas ça
négligent le petit rock puisqu'on avons
n'oublie de sortir le fouet et fit en
hobbit sortir ces pièces mais en
revanche c'est un coup très souple qui
permet développer notamment le cac vb 8
soit sur la casse et 6 ici soit sur un
15 17
dire qu'on ne donne pas encore laquelle
la position on dit pas si on va jouer
avec g6 ou avec le 6 on peut encore
s'orienter de temps en temps vers des
systèmes indien avec les six donc ça
laisse les blancs c'est un coût qui est
utile on va dire dans le main event
souvent parce qu'il faut contrôler cette
case dissiper 5 notamment parfois pour
jouer le pion en bsb 5
c'est ça oui audience à l'utilisateur le
défi à chaque fois et est donc ça laisse
toutes les opportunités de jouer soit
avec le petit centre 7,6 soit g7 g6 soit
plein de choses alors l'inconvénient
évidemment de socoa 6 c'est qu'on risque
de se faire pulvériser effectivement pas
celle des blancs une sorte et pièces
très très vite et sont donc très
efficace alors on va voir ça tout de
suite
f3 donc acquis 3 donc en fait c'est pour
jouer à tampa l'attaquant mais avec fo 3
disons qu'elle est le fond 3 voilà et
donc sur faut 3 elle a vu que j'ai de
temps en temps jouer kg 4 ce qu'elle ne
peut plus revenir sur le kazakh 4 et
donc elle veut que je rentre dans mon
système avec avec 5 donc on veut avoir
pour parce qu'elle pense que c'est pas
très belle envie que l'on dit mon
système c'est effectivement un système d
un des rares joueurs à conserver dans
son artillerie non mais voilà je suis le
seul comme l'irak est chef quatre chefs
manille j'étais seul grand maître à
jouer ça et j'étais le seul à perdre si
c'est vrai que j'ai un très bon discours
sur ses pas forcément écouté d'une autre
oui d'accord mais jugé sur cinq face à
des grands maîtres 1 c'est dur et j'ai
battu sans tourment
autant alors on va voir ça quelque 3,5
voilà ça c'est sa force quasiment tous
est certes un thème bien jusqu'où en
tout cas voilà moi j'aime bien parce que
aussi je trouve ça aussi c'est ce que je
vous kasparov mais c'était ça donne des
lignes encore plus tendue que ça si l'on
risque vraiment de se faire mater le
coup alors que 5 normalement ça engage
le combat plutôt autour de la caste des
ça fait un jeu plus positionnelle ou en
général ans pour moi l'attak dans la
dans la gueule et ses lumières
alors donc ici judith sur son cavalier
qui est attaquée à fait normal et là aux
premiers coups intéressants des noirs
fait de langue l'idée c'est de lutter
pour cette case des 5 1 avec le cabinet
sis qui protège et de pouvoir pousser
peut-être plus tard le coût des fils des
tout à fait alors évidemment les blancs
ont intérêt à essayer de verrouiller les
alfa brera et menaça menace aussi les
empêche aussi de ce pas une menace parce
qu'on le stéphanois n'est pas encore
développé quelques on n'est pas des
bienfaits pas offrir de sortir ces
pièces alors faut trois normales ou
développement au niveau on prépare le
grand roque a priori c'est assez logique
puisque quand on avance et plus ou moins
légers 4 on vous faire le grand quand on
avance ses pions fc bien le leur au quai
du petit côté s'est affaibli ce rond
point que l'on préfère le qe2 évidemment
tout à fait comme diraient les cif
dorfman alors là maintenant
kamali berne 17 ici ce que va dire
dessin alors c'est quoi il va venir en
v6 se parler plus tôt ou tard en fait
j'aimerais bien pousser b5 et le mettre
en mai 6 1 pour contrôler la classe de
ce1 qui les croient
voilà tout par exemple si je m'étais ans
et si ça qui est par là qu logique pour
sortir une pièce est menacée dès 5 ans
si tu l'avais mis ici sur la casse et si
ça paraît plus logique mais il ya
cavaliers des cinq médailles le elle
occupe la case way et en plus elle me
l'a soulevé six avec 10 des templiers de
métro c'est bandant c'est horrible on
est obligé de prendre les 5 et c'est le
cauchemar il faut contrôler les caisses
noires 1 de la série culte prendre un
des 5 pourtant seul but en blanc qui
simule un bluff oui mais on est obligé
d'attendre du doute de donner la paire
de fouet en est le foot blanc devient
très fort donc qu'elle ait des dessins
qui arrivent et 17 là où j'ai un g4
alors j'ai quatre l'idée c'est justement
d'empêcher ceux des 5 et 6 oui c'est
dire que de répondre à b5 par g5
chassant le khalife 6 avant qu'ils
puissent retourner sur la caisse 17 ces
temples à 15,17 n'est pas libre ouais il
ne peut pas revenir sur la case des
c'est ce que les blancs estiment que
lecavalier sera moins bien à 517
alors stéphane pour bien que ça puisse
être compréhensibles par nos internautes
qui nous regardent mais on peut
envisager au lieu des 4 le ku'damm d2 je
pense que c'est une bonne à imaginions
dams et 2 une bonne option s'ils en
prennent leur temps joseph d2 par
exemple donc donc on voulait bien là on
joue les cinq ans jour et b5 et
maintenant si les blancs jouent g4 à ce
moment là d'accord qu'elle venait en v6
qu'un malien betis est maintenant sûr
j'ai cinq ici est bien le cas mais l'île
pour y revenir sur la case 17 où il
serait plus actif ça qu'on fait il
suffit d'un temps au noir pour pouvoir
libérer cette caste des sept maîtres
lecavalier là où ils ont envie de mettre
d'accord alors que la en jouant au lieu
de 2 d2 le coup j'ai 4 tce 4 et bien
maintenant
après b5 qui se la joue et ça si l'on
sait ce qui s'est passé donc on va
revoir le groupe de laurent b5 et bien
chaissac gsm et de caméline là ne peut
pas à 20 ans près ne peut pas revenir
ainsi donc il va se positionner sur
cette case du sort et il sort et moi un
petit pas de bol quoi
bon mais je connaissais j'ai fait ça
plusieurs fois d un choix qu'on est
banalisée une partie chondrites choc qui
est exactement pareil jusqu'à un certain
point c'est pas me bloquer l'accès aux
zones a commencé ce weed ailleurs
avalisé la partie qu'on me le dise
exactement pareil pour revenir dans les
archives d'ailleurs il avala les
archives de diagonale peut enchaîner des
gones à pourvoir est parti enfin le
diagonal consacre aux zonal de mandor
qu'en fait le cavalier pas mal parce
qu'ils empêchent ils empêchent la
progression des pions et droit mais d'un
autre côté c'est vrai qu'il est quand
même assez dangereux ça va venir sur la
case f4 pas tout il va se faire prendre
et hillion ademe des deux ans a perdu
pions c'est au prix d'un pion c'est donc
voilà donc ici johanne gauthier avait
joué donc on peut voir ce que je lui dis
peut-être mais la vie d'homme donc je
vais lautier et jouer et choisit caïds
et 5
d'accord je le tue avait joué donc le
coup plutôt cavaliers c'est rend à
rennes j'ai boxé par lautier fedorov mon
jeu ça donc ils sont de grands
spécialistes fedorov qui est reconnu et
green shoots majou nm dès 2 donc être
choqué paul garraud jouer dam des deux
est l'outil iphone enfin joe kay des
sacs avec tous là à noter que j'en ai
marre que le rôti joue cette variante la
voilà mais je pense sont la référence je
pense que khalid et 5
je sais vraiment pas grand chose j'étais
bien de rejeter j'avais des positions
correct comme l'outil est fait de
rencontres fedorov j'étais gagnant et
qu'on authier je pense que c'était donc
dème d2 et le vol d'un des deux pas mal
donc l'idée d'un des deux c'est de
permettre de grands qui est aussi sans
pêche le calédonien vers 4h quand même
temps fou et d'un contrôle cette quasi
tout à fait donc c'est un coup à double
double fonction alors fawcett
c'est pas mal aussi ça ça sort le foot
puisse avoir une petite pression sur
versailles ça peut jouer ça oui puis en
plus ce qu'on peut devenir maintenant
être car peut-être l'avion cavaliers 20e
mais le moment à l'abri non c'est pas
mal peut-être que oui peut-être
peut-être peut-être mais c'est vraiment
ça sert pas à grand chose mais tout cas
venu avec 4,2 sur les blancs comme joue
h 2 h 4 où il est prévu pour défendre
l'option g5
ensuite ils attaqueront le cavalier
alors franck normal mais laurent l'abri
donc les blancs quasiment fini leur
développement
voilà mais plus que le fouet fin
peut-être donc on peut on peut dire je
suis mais développer un élément dix ans
j'ai tout du taiso sortie à part un
congrès de vienne mais le gros problème
c'est à dire que si les noirs jouent
petit rock et ensuite commencé à
attaquer ça va être très bien pour eux
le problème c'est quand même à quatre
des cinq pour l'instant c'est qu'à lyon
il s'installe et les pulls insisté sur
cette case
il souffre est une plaie non à noter que
les blancs n'ont pas d' attaques n'ont
pas vraiment de plan d' attaque directe
c'est ou alors c'est assez long ça
serait peut-être hkd soit je crois je ne
sais pas y a pas vraiment danser le vent
ces cavaliers dessin qui s'écaille des
5es avec installés alors le cavalier ici
voilà qu'il faut prend puis on prend et
cavaliers à 5 et l'installer en c6
d'accord mais ça on va le voir ça cela
retombe en amont vouloir d'un groupe
local et en descente mais tellement
grosse pression sur les noirs alors
l'une des noirs font qu'elle épaississe
pas mal c'est d'un ridicule et des six
matchs toujours la partie quand il est
chaud voilà le jeu était très inquiet
car il peut éventuellement venir sur le
causse ces quatre là tout allait
concerne la classe de 5 mais il est sous
le feu du fou ici comme tout à fait
faire attention et la up
judith joue le coup qu'à valider cinq
donc ça revienne c'est la même idée que
joue l finalement la journée par des
bienfaiteurs joël jouaux elle voulait me
prendre beaucoup de caisses noires mais
parcequ'il est important pour pour
défendre pions des 6 après un accord est
en fait j'ai pas de problème pour le
défendre défendre sociaux outils web
voilà voilà ça y est le foot quasiment à
un important point les voyons si c'est
le bonheur des plantes rcm de suite mais
menacé le demande le fou nous resterons
en septembre le cavalier aussi ses
parents le fou et éventuellement après
le dingue pour une beauté de cavale yvan
xo et le prix de provoquer les décisions
prises c'est pas mal non plus si cette
emprise puisqu'elle est fou il ya le fou
au travers et le cavalier ici nous
menacer là un moment où j'ai dit
la partie contre kd choc alors là donc
je joue et a choisi trois vallées prend
j'allais jouer cahier prend calais prend
cavaliers et là tu as choisi fou prend
cavani voilà donc c'est la nouveauté
c'est qu'elles n'ont au mieux dans mon
expérience mais disons que c'est assez
connus de cette position cas d'accord
donc là on comprend cavaliers forcée
voilà quasiment fonctions oui parce que
jouer faut prendre ça au sérieux ça n'a
aucun intérêt
tours s'est vite donc ça c'est pas mal
ça me coupe développe et édite à roncq
est tout de suite donc non en fait il
faut expliquer c'est que si je fais pas
tour c'est 8
il ya cavaliers à 5 ouais ça dans leur
tente donc alors ce cavalier ici qui
viendrait sur un 15 à 5
et pour l'un c'est si devenir ans et 6
ans mais là il ya toujours camélia ça
qui est aujourd'hui un des cinq
d'ailleurs il faut jouer notre suite ma
part des assureurs grâce au pire on est
le pion qui prend les mêmes menaces en
fait ici c'est de jouer kelly c4 est
maintenant sûr on va supposer un coup
notre sous région ouest 4 sur 12 en
prophylaxie dès lors jouer ça j'ai bien
joué ça cavaliers c4 1 qu'aller c4 il
faut prendre un vol un métier et là j'en
prends qui on comprend et maintenant si
lecavalier bien sauté à 1,5
oui pose ses trois amis c3 et la pièce
la dame est attaqué et si on prend avec
le pion voilà et bien apprend que le
cavaly ci n'est plus protégé par la dame
et des noirs pourrait prendre le
cavalier la dame large
c'est cette fusée l'idée donc c'est donc
le triage voilà c'est le aux femmes pour
nous pas pour lui l'idée dé nord
justement c'est de jouer qui a laissé 4
qui empêche pas le cahier de venir aura
cinq donc sa passion pour revenir dans
cette passion voilà mais évidemment les
blancs ils vont tout de suite et blanc
vont tout ut15 l avantage c'est que ce
que malia 5 non seulement menace
peut-elle devenir ans et 6 mai en plus
contrôler la casse et quatre mâles a
tout donné donc là il ya eu 10 et ya un
petit truc technique pour l'ena oui donc
ici qui est connue donc cavalier prendre
les accès ce que je joue
c'est la partie c'est la première marque
à l'épreuve des 5 donc voilà maintenant
le pierre ici c'est que les blancs
pourriez alors l'idée l'idée c'est que
si les blancs prennent le cavalier blanc
et noir reprennent ici de cavalia se
déplacer c'est ce qui sépare alors le
piège est en fait ici c'est sûr
cavaliers bessette
il en a gagné voilà on alors de gagner
une pièce pourquoi parce que l'idée a
mis d'accord a expliqué le cavalier
c'est que l'idée c'est que on prend les
blancs prennent le clament les dessins
et protège le relais dames voilà c'est
ça oui ou oui mais là justement il ya le
coup c'est james et 7 et maintenant on
s'aperçoit voilà dames c'est cet élément
s'aperçoit que si on prend le cas au
lycée cheikh ayman a ici les blancs
prennent le cavalier qui a l'air bien
parce qu'on protège le cavaly dans
l'impression de gagner une pièce mais on
perd le roi et voilà mon père le roi
puisque les noirs forêt échec et mat
en c2 voilà le baiser de la mort voilà
donc les lamas en fait donc donc en fait
ici après dance et c'est télé les blancs
sobrement de son clip donc ça leur
budget voyage à l'heure mais pour le
moment puisque normalement dû gagner 16
voilà je gagne un pion je sais même pas
j'ai même pas lire je gagne plus alors
les dracs des notions bien dans mes
pairs de fouet qu'elle blanches sont
très affaiblis donc on va regarder
ailleurs la partie donc madame cavaliers
donc c'est judith à l'axé lors de cette
rupture ça c'est très con c'est encore
connue donc là c'est la partie d'un dos
et en fait ça il faut dire que ces
consignes 1 et c'est considéré comme
trop mauvais pour et noir mais j'avais
une idée
j'avais une nouvelle idée d'accord mais
je dissocie mais ans judith n'avais pas
d'idée a réfuté mon idée la rumeur sur
la chine attache une idée avant la
partie j'avais une idée j'ai joint à
partir une demi-heure donc marie dont
j'ai perdu en une demi heure parce que
tu pensais retrouver quelque chose avant
la partie quelle analyse à j'ai trouvé
quelque chose d'avoir un parti mais il
se trouve que ça marche pas a et donc je
pense que c'est important dans cette
position de préciser pourquoi les blancs
seraient moins bien passerait mieux avec
un point de moins alors déjà la première
remarque c'est effectivement toutes les
cases blanches et notamment la dame en
d5 d'amendis flop complètement donc le
pion aux des six le pion aux cinq qui
bloquent cette option est plus un
bouquet il bloque donc le fou noir en
cette le fond noir recette est très
mauvais fini peut pas sortir
ok il ya le fou est cinglant qui va
s'amuser d'ailleurs s'amuser parce qu'il
a toutes les cadets langil sans
merveilles prochain coup on sent qu'ils
sont disponibles pour lui pour attaquer
au canada corp ici les plans jouent et
s'amusent dont quelques uns jouent et
s'amusent d'abord fois je crois pas mal
l'idée c'est déstabiliser la tour s'est
vite là qu'est pas trop de cases en fait
en disant qu'elle n'avait pas trop de
bonnes non mais par exemple si un levier
voilà s'il vient par exemple s'est
viandé 8 ces vidéos et bien tout
simplement dm6 échec celui de foot et 6
pour l'être darcis 6 échecs le roi
bouche par exemple en ingénue fuite est
maintenant sous b6 arnaque
la dame est là pour gagner une pièce de
lillian la qualité puis il ya peut-être
maintenant
mais voilà peut-être tafer donc c'est
terrible donc là j'avais toujours prévu
évidemment non mais elle a commencé à
réfléchir elle se doutait de quelque
chose à penser oui je trouve ton
séquelles je voudrais qu'on sort touché
après tour c'est comme toucher 4 allée a
commencé à vérifier ses variantes elles
connaissent évidemment pour ces 4
l'avantagé c'est que cette tour continue
contre la casse et si l'on peut pas
faire envers dams et si ses chevilles et
sans contrôle aussi la case africaine ce
qui peut dans certaines variantes être
pas mal ça qu'on prouve cette can et en
plus la tour a défendu donc ça c'est la
source assez bien effectivement est
défendue par le pion ça c est donc à ce
qui était considéré donc paré théorie
donc pour ces quatre noms moulin le coût
normal c'est le cavalier mais non on
voit le cavalier l'allemande donc full
attack in construit bien joué oui vous
avez donc elle a joué avait qu'à pas oui
d'accord
ah oui il y avait la taille de la cedh
est considéré comme un gros avantage
blanc ouais bon cette partie cherche pas
l'évaluation de dix ans que vont les
gets in dans la ville était en fait ici
les baignoires a été d'analyser
considérer qu'ils étaient permis
baissent ce coup semble curieux fuji cas
puisqu'ils ont fait le caillage saines
colères pas bien placé oui mais en fait
l'idée c'est de ces deux donc on va voir
la partie voilà manquerait plus tard est
ce que le non emploi
on peut par contre j'ai 6 on ne peut pas
juger 6 on peut parfois jouer parce que
je suis pour protéger le câble
lecavalier juste énorme
en fait au coude avant on pouvait faire
d'amabilités chèques des dames des 8es
dame prend 1,6 et là il se trouve que je
faisais petit rock et j'ai beaucoup de
jeu non les mémoires plus faire pire ok
là et avec le avec frange saine qui on
prend elle saigne le tyrant sera
complètement dégarni et on va montrer
remonter cette variante admettons donc
c'est pour voir g6 si l'énorme chien fou
prend 1,5
donc la foux prendre 5 tu comprends
maintenant damas huit échecs
voilà d'amd 8 20 minutes ou forcés sinon
nous perdrons une plante et ce qui se
dit ou reprendre ici c'est ainsi dans le
rétro fillon d'amd vite d'un principe on
récupère le plus en vue caméra et d'un
autre variante et le faut un strike
avait lieu le 5
ouais on a joué au jeu de tir auquel
beaucoup de jeu vu que les toutes les
colonies sont ouvertes sur le roi mais
l'apd iran que oui
la team rocket apprend et déjà il ya
plus il se voit même voilà les noirs
aussi en premier avec le rock
tout à fait c'est possible n'est pas un
attaque aussi qui peut se monter boule
noire mais j'ai quand même assez j'ai
pas mal regardé cette pétition est donc
je pense que non le problème sur cinq
ans suite à de gros analyse noble
nouveau analyse d'augmentation vaudois
dévorer les grosses anaïs d'hautmont à
part qu'on va pas d'évoluer sur les
lieux alors ici tu choisis donc se jouer
dans les deux cas voilà ici le cavalier
et sur l'a 4 4 et voilà maintenant on
peut donc fou prend donc ça c'est le
seul coup là les blancs très lecavalier
puisque le lac avaient attaqué la
dernière évidemment maintenant le pion
prend soin est ridicule du tout rachat
par exemple coup le futsal il faut
absolument pas vraiment pourquoi un tel
coût serait désastreux pour achever
parce que simplement les blancs de
développement dernière pièce ici en es
ça y est naze tout reprendre cette même
déjà ça y est le roi noir est au centre
des perroquets sous peine de perdre le
fou il ya une grosse attaque pour les
blancs très grosse adresse
disons qu'à vouloir imposer ceux qui
attaquent généralement qui viennent
d'accord sortir ces dames et sera
opposée favorise énormément latavala
c'est sûr alors là vous prendre donc
voilà du coup tout reprend et c'est
maintenant qu'on comprend l'idée de
toucher 4 c'est que maintenant cavalier
f4 fou prend avec 4.4 on a réussi à
dévier la tournée qu'elle sait si ce
avant la société tracé si ce n'est plus
protégé par la tour la toile à agen ne
contrôle plus l'idée de fuji cap s'est
tous dit n'est assez profond donc les
blancs peuvent faire petit frère il ya
réfléchi voilà tchèque voit la parcelle
ennui c'est toujours avantageux de faire
en échec avant que les noirs évoqué
c'est que c'est ainsi le noir les rois
le roi pendant obligé de bouger ce qui
le cas on peut plus hockey et de la tour
qui a choisi de se retrouver au jeu mais
ça dépend si ce tour ne pourra pas
sortir enfin beaucoup de mal aux faut
espérer qu'elle sorte mai
pas sûr donc on est cuit alors quoi futé
forcément on peut voir leurs rentes sont
rendus trophy est maintenant en cours il
ya maintenant deux heures il ya des 7 nm
ces échecs et mat
la preuve c'est non mesdames ans et va
très compliqué du coup on n'a pas le
choix
donc du coup j'ai pas trop réfléchir sur
ce coup là joe dit au revoir et c'était
toujours noir mais année nous sommes là
en fait on parle ici c'est le coût
normal tout reprendre des six alors
pourquoi ce que normal qu'elle soit sur
la séquence est fils de qualité est-ce
qu'on peut acheter un coût normal c'est
pas ça fait fils de kate aime parce que
si tu prends ton moi c'est très fier de
qualité je vais te mater d'accord donc
jamais surprendre et ses sagas nature
d'accord donc ce coup dur mais on va
voir on va voir pourquoi les noirs
peuvent apprendre dans la tour c'est
important de montrer les variantes alors
la food rend en vidant ainsi le roi bien
où j'ai vite il est tout simplement la
dame coréen daewoo avec échec est
l'échec suivi le match du couloir quoi
classique et sur rouen 8 on va pas
chercher un matin et ce roi 8 je joue
dame prend 1,5 simplement et je prends
la tour et j'ai une pièce de plus mis à
mal hier matin ah oui on fait simplement
il faut alors la mhf trois en huit jours
c'est fou au cices non non non ces six
ans
ainsi huit forcé 17 et lui baiser de la
mauricie décidément c'est judy que
bafa ou le taf a vu que j'ai dit que
face à l'obésité maths alors dans ses
photos en décision pouvait envoyer donc
ici c'est la position les années il
s'arrêter là et mettez plus ou moins
saillants plus ou moins ça veut dire
avantage décisif blanc et avec en mai
donc voilà j'ai cherché ouais et je me
suis dit il va falloir essayer de sortir
le roi oui et pour sortir un torrent
freak donc j'ai joué un coup logique qui
a jamais été analysée avant je cette
justice avec brouiller cette que le noir
s'il est roi noir
si la mort arrive à mettre le roi loi
bar le roi ici au g7 est de sortir la
tour par exemple sur la classe je sais
pas moi mais pour tous dès 8 oui oui non
mais en fait c'est aussi ça c'est bien
pour l'ennemi en plus j'ai beaucoup de
menaces dans cette position lorsque vous
faut prendre tour et d'emprunt de aussi
avec une héroïne attaque les noirs il
faudrait une contre-attaqué gens à deux
une contre attaque qui risquerait une
ferme donc enjoint soukous jécistes très
vite les échecs du couloir et j'ai fait
loi et voilà tous taillés jeunesse de m
domaine mort en insécurité et tu me
donnes tu menaces de judith a réfléchi
très longtemps sur ce coup là et m'a
joué un excellent coup que j'avais prévu
dams et 5 voilà donc c'est le court
j'avais prévu mais ça paraît paradoxal
enfin l'idée d'attaquer sur cinq mais ça
mais quand même la dame et la tour odéon
l'alignement voilà un tacle le kiosque
il aura pour toujours
isabella si je fais dame prendre l'idée
c'est au tour des mythes échec
avec tout ça on va montrer sinon après
nature à ne laisser pousser l'idée de
mettre en alignement la victoire il ya
demain c'est tous des huit échecs le fou
ne peut pas prendre la tour puisque les
glamies si fort échec au roi donc c'est
interdit donc il faudrait la faire
ranger set et là d'un problème est là
dedans promet chèque de 5 pardon des
jeunes arrivent pas dames 35 avec l'
avantage décisif 6 pi et noir n'ont pas
de solution simple pour s'en sortir
voilà donc dame c5 donc là tu as choisi
donc là j'ai surtout 3g 8go j'évite
force et je l'avais prévu ça j'avais
prévu encore c'est toujours été dans tes
analyses voilà c'est marqué dans
l'ordinateur
moi j'évite dans le marseille faisait
nul ça s'est mal passé ses voeux le
passé d'accord roger 8 d'anglais et ne
prendront 1,5
c'est ce qu'elle allait prendre le temps
d'arrivée cinq attaques la tour est fou
voilà donc ça c'est la très fort puisque
la tour et le fou sont attaqués donc
inconvénients évidents c'est qu'il faut
pour tous défendent et font la tour est
apte à kadam il faut pour ses looks à
jouer je sais ce que fait leur grand
tour vous prendre pour il faut prendre
le vous voilà et maintenant on sort la
tour ans et 4 et des analyses salariaux
et la non mais année ils s'arrêtaient
pas encore là ouais ben ali s'arrêter à
la donc le logo des normales donc là je
dis que c'est un peu normal fait d'abord
échec louis roger 7 à leur place saddam
en fait sur la case
voilà une salle de vie s'arrêter là et
celle perpétrée
parce qu'en fait c'est vrai que si
j'arrive à jouer james et 7 par exemple
oui si les noir et blanc je vous dis
c'est par exemple fait jouer un coup
quand on croit bien admettons ouais elle
parce que vous aimez tant que le voilà
ce qu'il faut voir dans un premier temps
c'est que si voilà c'est justement les
blancs les noirs les blancs arrive à
laisser la dame aurait 5 ans contre 20 4
g7 la tourache 8 noir ne sortira jamais
voilà est-ce que le roi peut pas bouger
donc il faut essayer d'échanger cette
dame blé noir pour l'instant
momentanément ils ont que tam est
toujours utilisé avec une tour qui
potentiellement est inactive 6 heigl a
réactivé c'est bien mais si j'arrive à à
chasser la dame de cette diagonale je
fais roger set et je suis beaucoup
échouent gagnant là c'est ce à quoi bon
donc c'est pour ça que ça c'est que les
bains avait pas le temps on est d'amener
est là les derniers retours à l'attack
2007 et sur damas ici s'il peut être si
on part sur d'un messi 6e je fais tour f
4 par exemple alors la tour f 4 et ça y
est la dame ne peut plus engager sur
cette diagonale toutes les cases s'en
sortir sont prises par les noirs et donc
après le coup suivant ses orangers 7 et
tout un tombeau et une fois que cette
tour elle est sortie si les noms qu'on
n'aborde pas mal tout à fait d'accord
puisque il ya une qualité
donc ça c'est l'idée voilà ça c'est
l'idée malheureusement après angers
uytsel a pas joué encore bien jeune et
je vais donner cinta même si je pensais
que ce coup là était vraiment pas
possible à cause de mon cotation de
delachaux obligé de fermer cet oued el
maleh ce domaine car ce chèque menace
d'amérique a triché menace d'un f4 échec
échangeant les
échangeant les dames ouais mais du coup
j'avais raté parce que la dame blanche
après sort à l'échangé à fab le fabuleux
conte du dit farah biocoal visite qui
fait mal qui a dû te prendre un peu tout
bon estomac touré chez pas compris tout
de suite ensuite alors non j'ai pas
compris parce que je suis demandé qu'est
ce qui se passait sur des russes 4 à 11
ans que mentalement on va voir et là
j'ai compris ou de 30 secondes d'un f4
échec tout simplement les blancs jouent
et wap et un roi b1 ses emprunts les
planches de nas bien les blancs menace
pour huit matches donc il faut prendre
l'ada blois linfo.re la dame blanche
n'ont pas le choix aux fellahs échec
intervient il a d'abord échec et sur roy
g7 puis on prend un homme qui vous
prendra échec pour apprend forcé oui et
on récupère la tour avec une caisse de
plus voilà tout à fait non c'est ce que
j'ai un énorme et c'est ce que tu avais
pas besoin d analyse économique y
trouver sur l'échiquier
voilà en terminant que j'étais minot
temps il faut qu'on m'explique t cfa 2
pour revenir à la position pour
expliquer pourquoi ce coût est très fort
donc déjà d'un f4 n'est pas possible
mais en plus ça crée une menace
s'accroît de menaces d'infiltration toro
huit matchs 1 tour 8 témoin génération
et des revers menace nat tout simplement
oui commandes la crise est là ça devient
très dur pour lyon puisque toutes
concédées par exemple ça n'améliore pas
du tout les pressions et noir jamais
après tout reprend ses droits bien
l'énorme plus d'échecs tout simplement
ils 5000 tours en prison et cette tour
est en prise avec le roi s'il fait la
dame on peut plus trop bouger quoi wet
voilà donc ici c'est pas possible il
faut pas envisager sa aubenas j'ai le
regret c'est de jouer un coup en
désespoir de cause sa chambre donc là tu
savais le rôle que j'ai essayé finir
quand tu as vu que deux mais quatre
marchés pas qu'on pouvait pas changer
d'âme c'est sait que micka j'avais pas
vu le coup d'après mais j'ai vu d'autres
variantes qui était qui était pas mal
aux hommes de mc 6 donc dame sait s'ils
sont contrôlés 8 sata contrôle à cazaux
8 et sa propre aux échanges des dames 1
évidemment si j'en arrive à changer
d'âme c'est toujours bien il faut
toujours pas d'ailleurs parce qu'il voit
toujours tour échec
oui mais là dix ans que je viens je
menaçais un coq au match 5 jeudi toro
aurait pu jouer droit bien
tranquillement on croit bien je joue à 5
oui et là je m'en sois d'accord mais sa
jeunesse voit on apprend même si ça peut
pas ce que j'ai à 15 h 7 pour moi et là
je dis trouve encore un coup de massue
quoi oui monsieur est évident que m
c'est assez évident on en fait c'est
quand même joli coup oui mais par
exemple j'ai trouvé un autre coup je
nettoie ne trouve sous 17 qui gagnaient
aussi un fou 17 à une idée si dame prend
pour 8.8 aidé à me prendre 17 tours 7
tarifs de 7 ça reste la même idée
d'ailleurs on va là donc il faut si
celle ci est encore plus sensible aussi
donc ça donne à cette menace dame prend
à vii matsa bien phu en prison donc
voilà donc j'ai hésité entre ça et entre
pions prend et dames 8e minute qui
semble cloué ça me poser les problèmes à
windham 800 le effectivement on va le
voir
et imaginons dames 8 et belhadj ou pour
protéger la casaque cette voie là on
protège donc si je pensais à tenir à
l'empotage l'a47 avec la dame et il est
autour d un bonjour bonjour et tour des
votes vraiment qu au moins six noms
maintenant car si haut sur dame prend
évidemment il y aurait tour ici mat avec
lui deux matches donc je reprends donc
là il faudrait faire tu en prends ton
des huit maintenant il est je pense
tenir avec tours s'est vite par exemple
autour des 8 mai on pourrait donner la
dame qui fondent au tour non oui mais la
torah chine soit une jouera jamais elle
sortira pas et ça se voit mais retour
s'est vite je me suis j'ai peut-être une
chance si je garde le plus réussi j'ai
peut-être une chance
c'est dans une station-service et vite
il ya la pointe d'énormes progrès dans
sa saucisse avec el cheikh
donc je parle quand même le pire aussi
ses matons h une sortie rajeunie et oui
parce que surnager cette on revient bel
adam moins de six lauréats redescend et
après en prenant un petit bleu roi c'est
un oui au bon sens
si ces développeurs essayent de sortir
on revient faire un chili on empêche la
torah suis dérangé advitam eternam la
fin alors donc tu as choisi de faire
j'ai choisi d'abandonner le plus vite
possible
tafer pions quand fou voilà et la tour d
un abandon lors en avait marre de cette
partie avec le problème c'est
effectivement ça on peut donner la dame
contre la tour dont le dr pour la dame
s'est fait la malle d'hérens édicules
par imaginons imaginons que ça aura pu
terminer par des huit ont fait la même
le mime variantes en fait tantôt des
vitres historians dément il attend aller
sans retour s'est vite c'est pareil
c'est lui et d'en prendre six échecs
avec un guide technique donc son roi ici
pour repêcher
on voit ici on prend la dame et après
tout reprend en fait d'un principe vous
faites un principe simplement et ses
pions l'avons s'avançait tranquillement
et les nets ont un point de vue on peut
bouger et que si on essaie de faire rage
5 par exemple qui a le plus changé six
fois la pensée dantesque important pour
les blancs c'est que le dol et ses sept
tours en soir comme la fuite il faut
empêcher le roi de sortir et parce que
si les tours s'activent c'est plus
pareil oui lui même même si les tours
arrivé à s'activer avec quatre points de
plus que je pense ça commence à faire
lourd et donc voilà donc des fêtes
désagréable à noter une fois de plus les
fans la préparation de l'ouverture qui
n'est pas toujours me donne un avantage
c'est une arme à double tranchant si
vous avez peu disons que j'ai marqué
mais donc c'est vrai je pense que sa
seule partie j'ai perdu comme ça sans
jouer parce que j'aime pas je vous dis
je vais finir par très bien se rendre au
scénario
oui mais elle est mauvaise et ça je
pense que l'avortement est tout
simplement je pense que là bas
maintenant bon peu de peut-être j'ai
trouvé quelque chose mais voir ça fait
plusieurs fois que j'essaie de trouver
et c'est chaque fois je crois j'ai
trouvé mes saignant je pense que la
position est pas très saine mais bon
faux faux faux je vais chercher
il faut voir la tâche d'orphée très
difficile moi je pense qu'il faut suivre
ce que je vous dirais kasparov
en général c'est une bonne voie donc a
priori plutôt orienté si tu continues à
persister
je vais plutôt le cou aux 6 ou autre
chose à voir en tout cas avoir un
attaquant donc je pense que l'on a déjà
ton année de toute façon est il vraiment
rêver les initiales variantes
j'ai passé une barre quand même la nage
dans ce qui demande énormément de
préparation théorique puisque c'est vrai
mais j'ai le temps ouais donc donc
double faute a pas de problème donc
c'est comme un peu c'est ça fait venir
est venu me voir après la partie est là
parce que c'est un peu le même style 20
devait y perd beaucoup de parties sur
les facturations comme ça mais n'a eu
cure stife était cynique où c'était non
sans humour bien sûr je reconnais je
connais bien je commence à connaître pas
mal de béni dans les wc de voir blanc
dès qu'on a rencontré plusieurs fois
mais voilà qui elle est très sympa
n'ayant atteint que 2 kim anh kim un peu
le fan est un peu chambré voilà bon ben
c'est normal on revient peut-être un
petit analyse des médailles par
échiquier puisque là aussi c'est aux
olympiades ont récompensés
individuellement les équipes
ou alors ajouté ces sources est souvent
un petit pays qui rend con carne qui
gagnent des médailles à leur passe quoi
parce que le système est un système au
pourcentage
c'est à dire qu'en fait on prend le
nombre de points à partir de je crois
que ces cinq six ou sept partis je sais
pas du goût de parti ni même à jouer on
voit le pourcentage est chic et pas
répliqué et ensuite on voit qu'il ya
quelques gros pourcentages
indifféremment de la force des
adversaires donc indifféremment la
moyenne à l'eau des adversaires ce qui
fait que si on met un très fort joueur
une petite équipe
ce très fort joueur va être opposé donc
à des joueurs woods hole et qu'ils
puissent comparer à 7 points pour
rencontrer des grans les grosses
cylindrées donc ils vont jouer que
contre des peuls un tsunami à des petits
pays et donc le joueur fort cette équipe
pour pouvoir marquer plein de points
voilà tout à fait ce qui nous donne donc
des résultats assez surprenants
par exemple au premier échiquier la
médaille d'or c'est pour monsieur à 10
ans le taux d'abonnées dit on connaît un
peu
karpov mais il fait même match nul donc
c'est effectivement tout à fait qui a
fait cet ennemi sur 9 83%
donc voila sinon on trouve après des
jolis noms genre troisième place casinca
nov
qu'un jeune qui joue très bien topalov
en sixième position 8e michael la table
sont celle çi 'robots' est le premier à
chiquer de toute façon les joueurs très
forts way et quand on voit shirov dans
l'équipe d'espagne qui fait du tennis
sur 12 c'est plutôt un bon résultat ça
par contre cette réforme c'est l'équipe
d'espagne est assez bonne en puissance
rencontrer des gros joueurs shirov lui
jouer des grands joueurs wii u nos
méchants fait il est très fort mais bon
il faut être inquiet s'il peut permettre
de donner un petit c'est un peu disons
il ya peu le même problème que moi avec
200 points de plus disons que avec les
blancs ils marquent tous les points
c'est vraiment c'est aux rimes et avec
les noirs moment il est un peu il est un
peu limite
on salue dans ce passage est donc le
cinquième site et alberto david l'équipe
du luxembourg connaît bien en france qui
termine cinquième au premier échiquier
deuxième échiquier donc numéro un et
bien ce n'est pas un petit joueur dans
une petite équipe
c'est un gros joueur dans une grosse
équipe c'est ruslan ponomariov qui fait
donc un pourcentage extraordinaire 61%
qui le actuellement le devenir le
l'adversaire numéro 1 etienne bacrot ou
plutôt etienne bacrot à l'adversaire
numéro un pour damon macro adversaires
puisque d'après laurent frayssinet donc
va passer à plus de 2700 au prochain
classement elo vidéo wii un avis assez
des calculs du sud n'y a pas de pas de
jeu pensez vous qu'une concurrence
il est logé ariel est un joueur à 2610
c'est un joueur qui va avoir de 1700
bientôt que tu vas tu vas arriver six
ans il doit bientôt non mais je parle
entre berck route pour le marié enfin
moi je pense que mon cheval
moi je pense que je vais y arriver très
prochainement leur disons qu'ils sont
eux ils sont calmes oeuvres à un mois du
jeûne
mais eux ils sont très jeunes ils sont
sur iphone disait il sent vraiment et
ils sont conditionnés dix ans pour
arriver à ce résultat là on nettoie
aussi tu mange des pommes
voilà troisièmes échiquier donc là c'est
des inconnus aux premières places
à noter que jeudi pour le gard qui a
fait un bon score 10 sur 13 dans
l'équipe de hongrie un homme s'est levé
night paris chic et on a parlé le
premier échiquier
c'est vrai que le joueur qui joue la
première place d'un d'une équipe mais
parce qu'il faut varier
non mais les formations sont données au
début du tour on peut pas changer et on
a décidé du veau premier chez qui font
qu'on joue tout en premier ainsi c'est
ça ou alors par contre si on est au
troisième on peut se retrouver au
deuxième si le au premier si les deux
premiers décide de sortir et qu'on fait
jouer les contres à fond
oui mais effectivement l'ordre dans
lequel les joueurs vont jouer des prêts
déterminés
donc il ya judit polgar 80 du marché
avec 10 sur 13 rebonds au score
jean-marc degraeve effectivement qui
était au 3ème et chic et sept sur dix
c'est bien aussi
voilà les notables un mot évidemment
très tendu
ça va être une femme est 4ème et chic et
c'est l'un arménien anastasia way à
noter quand même qu'il ya des joueurs
comme ça aux olympiades qui jouent dans
des grosses équipes qui sont très forts
qui marche très bien
ouais et qui arrivent à faire du
meilleur pourcentage que des bons
joueurs dans les petites équipes ça veut
vraiment dire que il se surpasse
complètement donc les arméniens on sait
qu'ils ont une capacité en équipe
vraiment se surpasser se dépasser on se
rappelle qu'ils ont comme gagner le
championnat d'europe par équipes en huit
ans d'un placement finales puis la
finale devant leur mini on est ok donc
on va plus y mettre toute façon
maintenant la france on regarde plus
derrière
oui en verve devant et on va pas vu leur
métier voilà on va gratter l'angleterre
et la hongrie
la prochaine fois pour les 4e et chic et
de la station pas mal qu'elle balayait
forte à notre ami qu'on salue qui jouait
aussi une orchidée kazakhstan sixième
position et aux sharks troisième avec
66%
voilà vous mais je crois qu'on va
arrêter là on a fait le tour donc
laurent qui restent avec nous
aujourd'hui puisqu'on reçoit vladimir
kramnik dans quelques quelques temps
d'un oeil aux deux heures lundi mercredi
que champion du monde qui vient faire
une petite simultanée en direct sur
canal web
à 20h30 c'est un partenariat avec
l'europe et chèques et ce sera
disponible en vidéo à la demande donc si
vous regardez cette émission bien direct
baisser tout de suite après et si vous
regarder en différé mais vous avez
normalement les archives de cette
simultanée de vladimir kramnik voilà la
prochaine fois
oui